hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be video all about how flash can
defeats avatars this season a lot of you
are also asking about Eddie Thawne stuff
so I'll talk about that at the end of
the video but there is going to be a new
round of the flash ring giveaway when I
post my flash video just be sure to
subscribe to get everything make sure
you click that bell to enable alerts so
you don't miss it in order to defeat
sabot are there a couple really
important steps along the way in a
couple of things that have to happen
so one sabot R is a being that exists in
this state between life and death
he's almost complete speed force that's
how powerful he is
that's why his lightning is white so
it's not like you could just stab him
and he would bleed out and that'd be the
end of it it also involves Barry
learning about his true connection with
the Speed Force they've kind of started
that this season you've learned a little
bit about that so the next big important
idea is that Barry will have to die in a
sense this season there's a couple
different ways that you could die he's
already shown that he's willing to do
anything to save iris and that includes
giving up his own life
there are really three big ways that
Barry could die this season on the flash
one savage car is able to kill him
outright
he's pretty fearsome already Barry's
already proven that he's not enough to
defeat him by himself - Barry could
offer himself as a sacrifice to try and
save iris and then three he could also
try to pull Savitt are back into the
Speed Force become pure energy himself
and try to battle him across space-time
for the rest of existence just to
contain him so that he couldn't hurt the
people that he loved that last one
becoming pure energy I'll address at the
end of the video because it has to do
with house avatar is able to manifest
his Speed Force armor so I'll explain
that at the end of this but we got to
talk about Barry rushing to judgment if
there's anything he proved last season
is that he's really good at rushing in
before he completely sinks through all
the possibilities I know there were a
lot of comments last year after Barry
willingly gave his speed to save Wally
in the others he had gone through the
Tachyon device he'd finally been able to
beat zoom but then zoom used his
humanity against him he used the love
that Barry has for all the people
around him against them and there is no
one right now that he loves more than
iris so not only are his enemies willing
to use that against him this is a
critical weak point because of what's
happening to iris at the end of the
season if they don't change things
everybody has all kinds of theories
about how they're going to save iris
maybe they're using one of Harrison
wells Holograms that we saw in a
previous episode they tend to do that on
the flash
they'll tee up an idea and is actually
getting ready to happen they're teeing
up something that will let you know
what's going on with the black flash
when he eventually shows up - but that's
kind of a separate thing because the
black flash is death itself - a
speedster so Barry's going to be
learning a lot about death this season I
know it sounds bad but it's actually
really exciting the black flash is
badass and he is not Zoom Zoom became
the black flash so when we say that he's
coming back he's coming back as the
black flash zoom himself is not coming
back but the thing is is if Barry is not
successful or he has to pull a hard left
turn go against the group and sacrifice
himself because there's no way team
flash would let him do that give up his
own life what would happen in the
fallout after that well we already know
that we have Wally West Kid Flash on the
show the whole thing that first half of
the season has been introducing him in
some of the other flash family members
like Jay Garrick and Jessie quick they
step in to fill the void but the thing
is is that in the comics after crisis on
Infinite Earths they teased that in the
season 2 finale which I'll explain in a
second theory basically sacrifices
himself to save the universe Wally West
picks up the mantle and becomes the main
version of the flash he wears a red
costume that looks like this
now it seems like he's wearing Barry's
costume but they change it just a little
bit there are a few subtle differences
like with the nose piece but that was
the ginger version of Wally West you
have to imagine the TV show Wally West
is in a mall gyum of those two things in
the cool thing about the ginger Wally
West in the comics the fidgets brought
back is that he still has the red
costume but it looks like a version of
his yellow Kid Flash costume and they've
teased that we're going to see a future
version of something that's really
special in comic book II they didn't say
which show it was going to be from but
it could totally be a future version of
Walli who has already picked up the
mantle of flash and is wearing a red
version of the costume now the other
option is future version of Barry Allen
but the whole idea this season is that
he's trying to kill Barry and even
though there will never be a flash TV
show without Grant Gustin they'll always
bring him back what they do is they find
ways to show you potential futures or
alternate realities like earth two or
three earth 19 where things went very
very different they have a lot of ways
to make things happen but then take them
back so even though the TV shows
combining a couple mark waves story arcs
to do the back half of the season is
terminal velocity which is a story about
how they learn what the Speed Force is
in how Wally West that versions of flash
becomes fully powered and then thus
Avatar Ark which came a little bit after
that but obviously they've changed the
way that savat are looks he's an armored
speedster they've actually done
something really cool where they're
combining ideas from those Mark Waid
stories where the Wally West version of
the flash who is the only flash at a
time Barry Allen is still dead and gone
people don't know that he's coming back
later so they don't know what the Speed
Force is yet they just know that they
draw from something that they call the
speed field and it explains why none of
them can run at the same speed why some
are faster than others you learn about
the deep connection that Wally has with
the Speed Force it's the same for Barry
Allen but you learn how when speedsters
die they're heaven is the Speed Force
they become one with that energy so
Wally learns that he can tap into that
and become even more powerful but in
doing so he will lose his humanity he'll
have to leave all his friends behind I
explained a little bit about this in my
flash powers video so I'll add a link at
the end of it but basically that's one
of two options that Barry has this
season he either
lets avatar kill him outright or two he
becomes so powerful that he becomes a
god speedster like God speed or sabotage
who's dubbed himself the god of speed
and starts to look like him as well so
this is where we get into these avatar
twists because why does he look like
that why doesn't he look like a normal
person all the other speedsters we've
seen even zoom who was crazy fast still
wore a real
Tivoli normal leather-looking costume so
what is up with the armor well in the
rebirth comics the really cool thing
that the ginger Wally West who has come
back out of the Speed Force tells Barry
he sort of makes fun of him a little bit
because he's still using the flash ring
to get his suit out
he says haven't you learned about Speed
Force constructs making the suit
directly out of the Speed Force so the
suit itself is basically just speed
force manifested into that material so
he doesn't need the flash ring and that
is probably why avatar has that armor
it's not like he climbs into a suit of
armor he just manifests it himself he
wears it around because that's how he
exists the idea that he's become so
powerful that he cease to be human
but because of the way he got his powers
Barry was able to trap him in the Speed
Force in the future so the whole
explainer about wise avatar is stuck in
the Speed Force if he's so powerful kind
of gets into the logic of the Speed
Force so I'll probably do a bonus video
for that in the next couple of weeks
once we learn a little bit more about
tv-shows avatar sometimes they change
things it's not always exactly like the
comics but I have a pretty solid idea
about why that is and it has to do with
the way he's connected to the Speed
Force in a different way that Barry and
Wally are connected to the Speed Force
here's the thing though even if Barry
goes away in present day he gets sucked
up into the Speed Force and learned to
enhance his power becomes this god of
speed himself that doesn't mean that
Wally would immediately start wearing
the red costume I would hope that they
would go with this design rather than
have him just wear Barry's suit so I
don't think that it's going to happen in
present day but it is totally possible
then in a flash forward either on
legends of tomorrow or on the flash we
will see Wally West in the red costume
calling himself the main version of the
flash in a time period when Barry Allen
has died because when you talk about the
reverse flash he's from the 25th century
that's from a time when there is no
flash there's no Speed Force so the way
he gets his powers is really cool we can
talk about that when he comes back
because Geoff Johns sort of rewrote a
lot of his continuity before flashpoint
is this really cool story to that I'm
hoping that the TV show does you guys
can let me know though
do you think that we're going to get a
flash of a version of Barry Allen dying
on the TV show in an attempt to try and
save iris do you think they're going to
try and play with our heads that way
because each season he's lost his powers
for a brief period of time in the next
logical step would be for him to give up
his life and go into the Speed Force to
continually battles' avatar to keep him
at bay so that he wouldn't be able to
kill the people that he loved but like I
said just remember there will never be a
flash TV show without Grant Gustin as
the main version of the flash so this is
all just flashes of potential futures
that they'll show us people always freak
out when they're like this while I
getting faster than Barry don't worry
about that kind of stuff in present day
Barry will always be the fastest version
of the flash just to briefly address the
Eddie Thawne stuff they were posting
pictures from the set like yeah it's so
good to be back so they're filming the
episodes that he's in which sounds like
it might be episode 18 but it looks like
it might end up being a flashback so
when we get some more information I'll
talk about it more but we do know the
Eddie is coming back so I know
everyone's really excited about that
what's going to happen next is is I'll
probably do a video for Jerome returning
on Gotham he's basically their de facto
new 52 Joker but he's taking a lot of
inspiration from Mark Hamill's version
of the Joker so I'll explain what's
going on because he basically just came
back from the dead so they'll be that in
a new episode of the flash tomorrow
night - well you guys wait for that to
post and click here for more flash
episodes and you can click here to learn
about the Flash's greatest powers this
season thank you so much for watching
everybody high five I'll see you in the
next video